okay what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel today
i don't have morning coffee thoughts but
i do have
morning
bagging chicken thoughts
i know
um i bought too much food so i have to
like ziplock it
and
i don't know this is something my mom
told me when you want to like save space
in your fridge
to take stuff out of the packaging and
ziplock it
so today
before i start don't forget to like the
video subscribe to the channel and send
them to our memberships i post some of
these coffee thoughts i'd say like 50
of the ones i've been posting are
members only so if you wanna see
exclusive like
coffee thoughts
subscribe anyways okay
so today i'm gonna talk about like
what happens when your dreams are like
coming true
and
i don't know i guess just how i got here
so
it's crazy because ever since i was a
kid i watched people like on youtube
when i watch conservative media and
i don't want to say i'm there yet
because i'm still like
like i'm still growing you know so
i'm not gonna act like i'm out here
there but i'd say my dreams are starting
to come true where i see myself it's
like really weird because
i i have a show and i see myself on
other people's tvs because they'll play
youtube on their tv and it's just crazy
to me that like
millions of people have seen my face and
i know who i am
which which is wild because i grew up
watching like
i was just different youtubers like ever
since i was a kid hold on
ever since i was a kid i've just always
loved youtube like
because i like the idea of that like
behind the scenes look
and
but i didn't start here okay so when i
was 22
actually let me let me backtrack a
little more
when i was in college the only thing i
cared about
was sports
and if i have one regret in life it's
not
starting a youtube channel when i was in
college because
i genuinely think i could have
made so much cool content like i was
funny in college oh my god
i have stories oh my god like we used to
do uh mattress sledding in the dorms
like down the
stairwell like i've always been on dumb
[ __ ]
even when i was a kid like i was always
the kid that they would pay me in candy
to do stupid [ __ ] at the mall which
could have been a youtube video like i
remember my friend paid me like 10
pieces of candy i was a fat kid um to
like literally put my head up to a
victoria's secret model glass
but i've just always been the type like
i just don't care because 90 of people
you won't see again so who cares
anyways
back to the
present so
when i got out of college
i decided that i wanted to stop drinking
because
one i was getting fat that was like a
primary motivator
and two i was just i'm a long-term
thinker even with this channel right now
guys i think so long term like i'm
thinking about
apps that i can make in two three years
time okay
and even then actually take around the
lights i don't think this lighting is
great
okay
better
see i don't know if it's better because
it's behind me i know this isn't great
lighting but whatever
so
i i was like okay i should stop drinking
so
i had a job offer between
milwaukee and chicago i was from chicago
and my thought was i'm never gonna stop
drinking if i'm around the same people
that drink so i moved from chicago to
milwaukee and intentionally was like i'm
gonna stop drinking i'm gonna make
friends with people that don't drink to
pursue this habit right
so i like started making i specifically
found a church that i knew had a really
good like community and i specifically
started making friends inside that
church
with people that just weren't big
drinkers i mean some drank but it just
wasn't
and i i lived with people from the
church and i was like great this is
my new
my new thing right
um and i and i should preface because
you will find videos of me like
drinking a little bit here and there but
i i knew i wanted to like because in
college
you guys know how college is not not
great for them
so
i knew i wanted to like cut back and and
and stop going to parties and stop going
out and for the most part like i cut
back so much slowly over time and then i
got to the point i didn't do it at all
so
so so so
that was step one
step two was i had a job offer in
milwaukee in chicago i took the one in
milwaukee and in milwaukee
i
it was actually a shittier job i could
have worked in tech don't ever work in
copier sales
i picked the worst job i know they tell
you not to bounce around in sales but
that's just the recruiters telling you
that because they get a commission if
you stay longer
don't listen to them they're they're
capping um bounce as quick as and fast
as you can
so
so
i was working with sales job for two
years and i just really was not that
good at it
um
i was actually terrible
partially because i went for like four
different managers but partially because
i'm pretty agreeable
and it was a pretty shitty product like
there's a lot of [ __ ] and it was the
worst and just oh my god my point is
this i did that for two years and around
the one and a half year mark i started
thinking like okay i'm 20 i think i was
22 when i started working there i was 24
when i quit
almost 24.
something like that and i remember
sitting in bed and i could not sleep
because i was thinking about how like if
i'm gonna do content creation like when
am i gonna do it because i don't wanna
be heavily
like when i have kids and a family like
i plan on
taking a step back and i was thinking of
all the [ __ ] i wanted to do and you guys
know me i have a million ideas so i was
thinking about vlogs i wanted to do i
was thinking about prank videos i wanted
to do i was thinking about political
media i wanted to do i was thinking
about like boom boom boom boom boom and
i'm like what am i gonna have time to do
this if i don't start now
because you want to get married you want
to have a family
i'm like you need to start now and i
remember thinking like i had this
overwhelming like
anxiety that if i wanted to do those
things because the other thing i want to
do is i'm going to produce an album
you guys wait for it i'm a good lyricist
i just haven't had time to do it or the
money albums are expensive i see why
musicians are broke but
um
and i was i just couldn't stop thinking
about it and i see people with this all
the time where they kind of want to do
it but they're just dipping their toes
into the water so you will never have so
success on social media unless you
literally go full force
this [ __ ] is so hard guys i've cried so
many times trying to make this
make this work oh my god i have cried
like literally cried
and
you make no money for so long but if you
can like
and a lot of people have this like ego
and this sense of pride i had none i'm
gonna be honest i had no ego i know not
everyone's lucky enough to have this i'm
just telling you what happened for me
i quit my job and i moved home all my
friends were partying in chicago living
their best life in their 20s from
college not that i don't even really
talk to them anymore but
not me
nayski
quit my job
i am
living at home with my parents which is
lame you kind of feel like a loser
okay wait can i make this
there we go
you kind of you kind of feel like a
loser because you are one
like let's just be honest
but
i kept watching gary v videos and he
kept talking about like all the things
you need to do to make this [ __ ] happen
and i'm gonna be honest with you guys i
made like
okay money
not even okay i made bad money
for the first two years
but
i don't know one day something just hit
and it was like everything that my
youtube manager was telling me oh that's
another story how i got my youtube
manager
um
everything that my youtube manager and
then i watched on youtube like
everything clicked and i stopped
freaking around i started treating this
[ __ ] like a business realizing you guys
don't subscribe to me for me you guys
subscribe to me for a specific type of
content and as soon as i did that
something clicked but people don't
understand like how long it took to get
the pieces in place like even my manager
i literally
he he's
a pretty successful like social media
guy um
just found out the other day i have an
mba so i was like okay i didn't realize
anyways um
but i found him because
i i messaged him on linkedin and asked
for career advice and he ignored me for
a year and then a year later i was like
i wonder if he's free maybe i can get a
hold of him and then i did and then he
like signed me
and that helped and
you know being willing to
take my hit to my ego and live at home
with my mom and dad helped and producing
thousands of videos and a lot of them
were shitty and some of them were really
embarrassing because they were so bad
but i just told myself if it's bad
content nobody's gonna watch it you
don't have to care like and people used
to make fun of me for having low views
like literally six months ago when i got
to england
the girls on my team are making fun of
me because
um
i have
no views on my channel and i get this
many views per video
blah blah blah blah blah blah it's crazy
because all the people that make fun of
you along the way are silent now and i
see it now even i just posted a video or
something talking about math making
i'm not even charging people i'm just
dipping my toes in the water seeing if
i'd be good at it i might at some point
i just like trying things
which guys
if you don't put in your social media
handles i can't contact you so a bunch
of you filled out the application but
didn't put any social media handles or a
way i can contact you how am i supposed
to help you
different different problem different
day but then the comments are you
shouldn't do this if you're not married
and i'm like guys then you do it do it
yourself jesus christ
what's it like
but that's how people are and that's the
thing like
you have to be so crazy to make like
like you have to be crazy enough to quit
your job that's paying you well it was a
shitty job but
it paid pretty well
quit your shitty job that pays well to
move home with your parents you have to
be crazy enough
to
not care about everyone making fun of
you because people do
and then you have to not care
and you have to be willing to do it for
one to two years knowing you're gonna
make no money and figure out how to deal
with that
and
yeah and like maybe it's been
waitressing or bartending or doing
something shitty maybe something you can
make content at if you can
talk about your job and like give
because people like to hear about other
people's jobs and other people's like
world views so if you can find a way to
incorporate that even if it's a
part-time job like you just have to
really reduce your standard of living
like i didn't go out i didn't drink i
didn't party i lived with roommates like
and don't get me wrong i i know i'm
privileged and i have a rich family to
fall back on but i'm not like a rich kid
where my parents just give me money
willy-nilly and
so
and all i can do is tell you what worked
for me and what helped for me and the
steps i took to get here maybe this will
help some of you i know the comments are
going to be like you are privileged i
know i am i'm lucky
but
behind every success story
there's a lot of [ __ ] that wasn't luck
that went into it so that's my coffee
thoughts
bagging chicken thoughts this is how i
got here
if that helped great if not no worries
bye guys